the two weeks this Mexican crematorium
has been going day and night the
exhaustive workers told us that almost
all of those here are covered victims we
are working the triple what we usually
do we just can't keep up before we were
married between one and three bodies a
day now it's up to 15 or 20 the
country's official covered death toe is
it just over 3,000 that's in a country
of almost 130 million people at the peak
of its epidemic there are fears in
reality it could be higher other
crematoriums report they're also at max
capacity like this one in its developer
on the outskirts of Mexico City
sometimes our ovens are so saturated we
have to cremate the following day we
leave the bodies at the hospital because
we have no room for them the country's
coronavirus saw said in April that the
real number of cases are likely to be at
least 8 times higher than the official
figure many other countries also admit a
data gap but it could be bigger here
because the testing rate is so low and
that goes for fatalities to Asians come
particularly in phase 3 in a serious
condition which doesn't give us the
chance to do the tests it could be done
after death but that rarely happens so
we have people that die and have the
symptoms of Kobe and Aaron registers
such but some local governments say that
on top of those problems the death tolls
they've reported haven't been reflected
in the federal count they counted us as
having 24 dead but we had 87 more than
three times more than up until last
night we had 54 people who died of COBIT
19 according to their medical
certificates and in the daily round ups
from the state and federal government
they've only registered 16 death
and meanwhile the fatalities continue at
this local cemetery they told us they've
been taken up to four times the normal
amount of bodies amid the worries for
some over transparency there is also
cause for optimism the Capitals health
system although suffering from a lack of
equipment and at times coordination is
still not overwhelmed even though the
government says that the epidemic in the
country has reached its peak the
government's hoping that it can get
through the peak period without huge
jump in the death toll whatever that
really is John Holman al-jazeera Jamar
what can